on
[Applaudissements]
nous en étions nous alors eric mendez
donc il s'est fait sortir c'était très
intéressant
j'ai passé trois heures à la douane avec
le fbi à
sa saison mitigée
merde mais ce n'est pas de ma faute
c'était quelques années après le 11
septembre poussée de la situation était
un peu tendue et il se trouve j'avais
été invité par le patron d'eurosport
patron de la coop d'eurosport mon ami
bertrand bruit donc j'embrasse aller
voir un match de l'us open la finale du
us open à new york un pas plutôt
sympathique voilà mais les a vus ils
nous ont plutôt respectifs ray pris un
avion le matin où j'ai plus qu'à leur
arrivée quelques heures avant le début
du match je me suis appliqué qui jouait
contre qui ce débat de fond c'est en
tout cas évidemment jamais arrivé il se
trouve qu'en arrivant à la douane au
monde passait à sécurité cetera j'étais
avec donc une copains bertrand bridon et
un autre ami qui était journaliste au
parisien je crois et à ce moment là on
voit dizaine de flics nous sauter dessus
le mec mais des mecs armés jusqu'aux
dents qu'avec des chiens et là bas nous
le dit
voilà je voyais déjà toucher rectal toi
parce que là c'était très chaud en fait
il s'est trouvé que mon pote tu me
disais qu'il avait rien à se reprocher
il n'arrêtait pas de faire passer de nos
bagages ou
[Musique]
nouvelles dans les machines pour scanner
ils sont finis par trouver drôle bagages
dans mon pote un couteau long comme sa
mère comme ça parce qu'il avait pris le
sac à dos de son fils qui avait fait un
ping pong avec sa classe
technique
c'est pour ça c'est ne sert qu'à cacher
dans le fond du sac de
jablé pas bien longtemps qu'on
s'explique usb pour dire que c'était
rien à voir que voulait pas faire de ton
texte et hazard total ont ils ont retenu
trois heures on arrivait il restait dix
minutes dans le match à peu près en
avait traversé l'atlantique pour la vie
de l'avion il doit arriver là il juste à
l'heure du match entre connais pas tu
des espaces à ce qu'on
écoute et non pas mal
j'ai fait chanter l'hymne de la cellule
avant c'était moi en tous cas mais non
on a choisi celle là oui bon c'est alors
touchera non mais non mais non les
vicois vous des prix de micro mesdames
messieurs chanté l'hymne de star ac mais
laisser la région vous êtes méchant
raconte m vous avez notre complètement
pourri
tu prends la vie comme la vôtre elle
m'inspire c'était la vie romain galy
c'est pour ça que yo compères note c est
à vous réchauffer avec sardou
des trucs un petit peu fou fou dans
l'avion parce que moi je suis une grosse
trouillarde doivent aussi donner des
cachets bon bah oui effectivement du
coup je prends des cachets je sais bien
que c'est pas bien et je vois en petits
coups apparentes supplémentation jamais
jamais jamais que ça ma famille comme
vous ouais mais donc tout le monde ne
donne des défis évidemment a eu donc ma
copine qui est avec moi me dit mais je
te donne un défi il faut savoir que dans
l'avion il y avait des corses on se
connaît tous qu'il faut plutôt bien se
tenir la corde puis comme l'était tout
le monde va se juger magana folle c'est
la femme qui chante dans l'avion
du coup à bagages chaque fois qu'elle a
patiemment les championnes chanson on va
dire c'est la folle qui chante dans
l'avion du coup je suis je me suis pas
débiné je dis ouais pas de problème j'ai
pris le micro
pour chanter avec moi et on a tous
chanteurs
et
c'est moi non alors franchement cemac
aux orties
déjà au niveau coûtait alors vous maître
capello de deux
des grands succès de dalida ouais ouais
j'étais avec la
wii pas très bien mon année c'est tout
alors il pris six mois ici qui disent
c'est bien ou pas bien et travaux neufs
c'était pas mal
alors on a d'autres un abruti ah oui
le
bien il demande à être sous placées dans
les recettes publiques dans l'avion on a
en a pas ou n'a qu'un souhait quand on
voyage c'est à dire si elle n'a pas la
chance d'avoir un billet
on est en écho aux et si je pouvais les
hobbies n'est d'avoir en première on
pourrait on pourrait manger sa mère pour
bien sûr et l'esa et louis il apparaît
la classe d'âge qui te fait sous passé
c'est le côté belge alors
j'explique j'allais au canada le canada
est un pays sur lequel la reine
d'angleterre
il a tjs royaume dans le commonwealth
donc je rentre et je n'étais pas du tout
en première et usage et on casse tout à
fait normal l'hôtesse très sympathique
vient vers moi et le musée monsieur vous
êtes grand oui je le suis grand je
mesure 1 m 86
il nous reste une place à la première
rangée
si vous voulez vous pouvez vous
installer à la première rangée ce sera
plus facile pour vos jambes je
mademoiselle me suis beaucoup je
m'installe et juste avant de démarrer
elle m'a dit écoutez monsieur il faut
que je vous dise puisque vous êtes à
côté de la sortie de ce jeu va vous
faire un petit et collages turbo écoutez
madame oui ok alors c'est simple
monsieur vous prenez vos deux mâles la
poignée de la cdc par les deux mains de
façon très ferme vous pilotez d'un tiers
de tours mais de façon très sec une fois
que vous avez voté vous pensé très fort
j'ai eu mon cas commence à s'emballer
s'emballer
mazel tous les gens ici moi s'il ya un
problème je serai jamais évacuée
vous avez rendu la place la bonne place
tout à la statistique les gens qui sont
tout à l'heure ils ont plus de chances
de s'en sort
tout à l'arrière où tout à l'avant parce
que vous savez
voilà alors j'ai fini dans un jet privé
avec des stars du foot c'est toi c est
bien ça c'est moi
vous savez pourquoi parce que j'étais
parti en espagne à ibiza tu avais signé
et on partait en fait seule une
compagnie low cost espagnole
on attend et il y avait un 1h 2h 3h ils
sont qui avait des joueurs très connus
je ne citerai pas qu'ils étaient dans le
même avion que nous alors pourquoi il
avait un vol low cost je n'en sais rien
ah oui le fait est qu'il est très énervé
pour vous trois heures on n'y est pas
d'informations qu'on n'ait pas pu avoir
un autre avion ils ont fait quoi ils ont
pris un jet privé d'en louer à l'instant
les prêts et vous pris avec eux pour mon
erreur
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous vous les citez pas par
classe rappeler même pas alors je
n'hésite pas par classe arrêté pour
certains sont des amis à moi
c'est
non on n'est pas sûr car vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que je lutte contre le poids
a
fait des efforts
[Applaudissements]
et tu dors lâcher pour lâcher ses voiles
à oui j'ai effectivement j'ai là entre
la et la wii a dit yahya 15 kg bien sûr
à 15 kilos de moins moi aussi
alors voilà et le dernier j'ai
transporté la contrefaçon légalement
ça c'est la dernière bah oui c'était
quoi c'était lui c'était du rock ça
c'était du rhum arrangé
alors ça c'est un bon petit fonctions
attentionnelles modération maîtriser
alors ça ça vous fait ils m'ont dit là
bas ils m'ont dit ce que j'en ai vu des
gens dit il ya un dicton tabac tue moi
nous sommes tus boit de l'eau
du bois de l'eau faire voilà voilà voilà
ça s'appelle à berck rase chez nous donc
la croise ouais on dit la crise en est
cette fois un peu écrasée à la wii ce
qui s'est passé alors ça sinon tu
t'envoles très loin avec alors non je
n'avais pas de rhum arrangé tout de
suite les clichés ne m'a pas du tout
vous savez vous voit plus non me voir la
drôme idiot vous savez que je suis très
très gentille et comme je voyage très
fréquemment j'ai une amie qui me dit bah
écoute ma meilleure amie toussaint la
main elle doit faire rentrer un colis et
où pour certains mangent une écoute moi
j'ai droit à 3 kg à 3 bagages quand je
voyage je peux lui prendre j'arrive en
martinique je suis quand même assez
connu là bas et on va non mais c'est
vrai
soit à l'aise on en arrive
divine
à l arrivée a pas de manque et à la
garde armée
on met à l'écart estime
[Musique]
à 10 comme ça
cet autre chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
cherchais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donc on fait facile mes bagages mais
savait aux rayons x est barack
obama
giuseppe voilà la star et la martinique
en fait quoi et si on doit parce qu'à
chaque fois que j'allais au passé il
pense que j'ai de la contrefaçon
c'est vrai
madame payé mon loyer mes livres il
commence à madame fait aussi mais vous
êtes malade ou quoi
[Applaudissements]
et
maintenant une petite bière
jus intrigue est plein de scotch marron
et tous les jours et à supposer note
mais ça ressemblait pas du tout que je
vous le jure que c'est vrai on me
demande ce que fait et j'expliquerai
touch peut pas moralement ce sont des
chaussures caisse elle m'appartient pas
là vous je vous laisse imaginer la suite
oui parce que ça c'est très très grave
absolument et moi j'étais pauvre il
était très gentil parce que justement il
m'a reconnu
les cours offerts
[Applaudissements]
je trouve ça marrant
[Rires]
partir avec et
gérer ses tournées sur des heures sur le
crêpe et alors on les mettra à l'essai
vous remercie allez merci pour le dire
on va passer ou jeter les amis
vous coiffer